este día en esta zona de taipei se
simula un ataque aéreo la atención con
beijing aumenta peligrosamente y la
inversión rusa ucrania ha hecho que la
guerra sea mucho menos abstracta para
los taiwaneses
tenemos que prepararnos más seriamente
para ser sinceros tenemos mucho miedo y
no hay forma de saber si la guerra
estallara también aquí en la ciudad
hasta 4600 sótanos han sido designados
como refugios para civiles en casos de
guerra e incluso algunos aparcamientos y
estaciones de metro por ahora en centros
comerciales subterráneos como este los
jóvenes llegan a pasar el rato pero
están conscientes de que esto podría
cambiar no nunca hemos conocido la
guerra desde nuestro nacimiento solo
hemos conocido la paz
siempre pensé que un lugar para ir de
compras así que cuando me enteré de que
en un refugio antiaéreo me sorprendió
mucho pero creo que es muy importante y
necesario el complejo de búnkeres de
taipei puede albergar a 12 millones de
personas más de 4 veces su población
este político también forma los
ciudadanos sobre qué hacer en caso de
ataque
cómo preparar la bolsa para llevar con
suministros médicos para ayudar a la
gente herramientas para construir aseos
y para separar el lugar donde se come
del que se usa para hacer algunos
diputados taiwaneses también piden que
los refugios se abastezcan de artículos
de primera necesidad por ahora las
autoridades se limitan a mantener los
búnkeres limpios y abiertos